for those that are not familiar uh
christopher ruffo you you've
i don't want to say what you exactly
specialize in but you definitely do
cover critical race theory which is like
this wokeness stuff
so i think you might have a lot of
insights into the motivations of at
least some of the rioters and some of
the things they've been protesting and
saying
as well as the actions taken by the
president i don't know if you want to
just mention a bit about what you do and
yeah i will and you know really to your
point about the unrest i was in dc all
day today i was meeting at the white
house and i went out to georgetown last
night and
throughout the city businesses are now
boarding up all their windows
they're putting up fencing they're
putting up barriers they're putting up
fortifications
the the kind of feeling just walking
through the city
is that things are going to pop off with
almost 100 degree of certainty
and my thought is that you know a lot of
these folks are
are are looking for any kind of
rationale
uh for going out in the streets so i i
think that uh
it's very likely to get uh to get ugly
to get feisty
everywhere election night and tomorrow's
a full moon oh no oh
dude oh my gosh all the time
yeah no no but but uh we were just
driving back because we're trying to get
set up for this we're doing this big
party we're gonna have a bunch of people
here and um
you know we're we're in the middle of
nowhere elevated surrounded by a bunch
of other armed residents it's a really
interesting property
and uh we're coming back and i'm looking
at the moon and it is ominous
it's big man i was driving up here and
saying like whoa i almost hit three deer
on the way in yeah yeah
there was like there's some vibes
happening yeah yeah for real
dude people don't you want you want to
know some some true facts
more crime is committed during full
moons yeah do you know that do the tides
no the moon i heard this would be closer
to the earth and would
have this real oval shape going around
the earth and it would pull the tides
like hundreds of feet in the air that's
a
long time ago there's a really simple
reason why more crime is committed
during a full moon right
it's it's brighter out yeah you can see
like i don't know if you've ever gone to
the middle of nowhere you know what's
really really cool is when uh
cause i grew up in chicago we would go
to the lake during a new moon
and it was the scariest thing you look
out in the lake and it was a void
like you couldn't see anything you're
like would you hear the water like that
see how you fall and you die
yeah during a full moon you can see
everything it's like reflecting so
we got a full moon and it's going to be
a saturday night full moon
just before the election halloween while
these riots are going off on halloween
yeah so uh so i i guess look um we i
wanted to open it
with this big update on on what's going
on with car written house it doesn't
it's not definitive of anything
particularly but it does have a lot to
do with the unrest we're seeing what's
gonna happen we got the election coming
up
and there's there's a lot of stuff to
talk about in this i don't know if
they're still doing it but i don't know
if you heard this
you know you mentioned they're boarding
things up did you hear that walmart was
taking the guns off the shelves and
hiding the ammo
yeah i'm just i i didn't hear that but i
it makes a lot of sense
i mean people are in kind of siege
mentality i've even heard a friend said
there's a shortage of toilet paper again
yeah there is
which is also weird it's like when did
this become the panic buying thing if
you want to survive
i feel like toilet paper is very far
down on the list
did you see uh you see what's going on
in paris i've seen a little bit of it
yeah like tens of thousands of cars
flooding the highways all gridlocked for
miles
like they're gridlocked because when a
traffic jam is so
big no car can move yeah i don't know if
you've ever played that game it's called
gridlock where you have
you'll have street and all the cars and
you got to move the car to like figure
out how to break the gridlock
but there's like when you have a car in
every direction
going you know up down left right or
north south east west they all block
each other
and so none of the cars can move in
paris they're doing new draconian
lockdowns
where you have to have your papers if
you want to go outside
proving you have a right to go outside
this is crazy
so people jump in their cars and they
take off trying to flee the city
stores are getting raided once again
it's like just like it was back in march
it's happening again
and it's a full moon it's halloween it's
election night lydia's not wearing her
mask
oh my gosh i'm not you're right i wonder
if this is like uh
the end of the simulation that's it you
know the culmination best part that's
for sure
we were uh we were just hanging out are
you familiar with simulation theory
uh like the singularity like ray
kurzweil or just like like
like matrix yeah yeah like our universe
is a simulation of something yeah yeah
yeah we were just we were just hanging
out and i was like what if what if we're
in the simulation
and everything we're doing feels like
the most important thing ever
and there's like donald trump is
president and there's a crime wave and
riots and things are exploding and then
they're like arming the news the
dictators are getting ready
and the guys running the simulation are
actually just tracking like the peruvian
dung beetles mating cycle
and so like we're in this simulation but
they're just like sitting at a computer
being like
the dogs hey did you see that in the
simulation donald trump is president oh
did you look at that anyway look at the
dung beetles they're mating this season
like a completely different kind of
thought process and brain their
interests are misaligned with ours yeah
like we think we're important we have
nothing to do with it
it's all about those beatles it's it's
it's crazy to see all this stuff like
starting to ignite right
again cause i'll tell you man usually on
fridays news is
slow and boring yeah you know and then
all of a sudden
uh today it was just like whoa there's
riots across europe
because of covet lockdown stuff toilet
paper shortages again
yeah now we got dc boarding up national
guard deployed in philadelphia yeah
riots in new york uh and now something
just happened
in where did it happen we just had
another we said another shooting of some
guy
another yeah yeah i i saw it on twitter
and i took a nap guys give me a break
it was a dude who was shooting at cops
and the cops killed him
and now there's you know writers coming
out friday night too
so oh man dude yeah man so
let's just let's just do this i i you
went on uh fox news
and you called on the president to ban
critical race theory
yeah does that happen that's how it
happened and it was a it was really a
kind of a process and
i did a number of stories on critical
race theory in government agencies so
the first one was in seattle
um where the seattle office of civil
rights ironically enough was hosting
a racially segregated diversity
trainings and the training for white
employees was called
interrupting whiteness and internalized
racial superiority
so they would have white employees come
in they would be kind of forced
to stand to say i'm i'm karen i'm a i'm
a she
her uh i'm white and um and then
essentially admit and then deconstruct
their complicity in white supremacy
struggle sessions struggle sessions i
mean it had all the documentation in the
charts and the graphs and
objectivity is racist and et cetera et
cetera and
and i kind of got my hands on these
documents for public records requests
and i said
this is crazy but it's outside of my
normal field of expertise which for the
last two years has been poverty
homelessness
addiction and urban disorder but i said
you know what i'm going to throw this up
on twitter where i'm just kind of using
my twitter account kind of starting and
i'll see what happens and then it's just
boom so then i write an article about it
in city journal and i think it went to
the new york post
and then i started just getting deluged
with leakers
and whistleblowers from everywhere in
the government
all of a sudden my inbox is just like
i'm in the treasury department i'm in
the fbi i'm in the irs
i'm in the you know the the epa i'm in
the
the justice department and they're doing
the same
stuff and that's the moment i said i've
stumbled on something
big and something that is happening to a
lot of people and people are saying hey
look
we can't oppose this i can't get up and
say
i think this is wrong i'll get you know
crucified i'll get uh retaliated again
so i'll lose my job i'll get
you know kind of turned into a pariah at
the office um but i really am deeply
upset about this and it's wrong and it's
a waste of money
so then i just went did story after
story after story and just you know
worked up the media chain
dropped it on twitter first linked to an
article and city journal or the new york
post or another publication
um and then from there you know booked
on on laura ingraham booked on tucker
wow and um and after i did that process
four or five times i created enough of
an evidence base
where it's persuasive that this is
happening in many places and then
tucker's producer called me and said hey
look i want you to do the monologue
with tucker carlson tonight and just lay
it out
wow and i said that's cool let's do it
and he says and he says all right you
got
two hours write the monologue that you
want to do tucker will set you up and
then
and then and then do it and i said all
right cool so i'm
i'm driving up to the studio and um all
right cool
you know read it off the teleprompter
and then and then we'll do it and then i
get a call to say
we couldn't book a teleprompter and i
said
okay and you said you're just gonna have
to just wing it
you have three and a half minutes you
just have to vibe on it and you're in a
dark room there's lights you don't see
him you see him in a little earpiece
and then um and then i said all right i
got this let's do it and and
i started feeling those butterflies a
little bit and and then tucker sets it
up beautifully and then um
and then i honestly i just kind of
blacked out i just like just
you know just got into the flow of it
and um and just
spit fire just rattled it out outlined
the research
um you know quoted the best that i could
kind of paraphrasing what happened
and then at the very end something i had
rehearsed and on the way on the
kind of riding in my truck on the way up
to seattle i said
you know and then i call on the
president of the united states to
immediately issue an executive order
abolishing critical race here in the
federal government
um i just said what what the hell go for
it you know
like do it and um and then could finish
up the segment and um i just had an
intuition a feeling i said
like this hit like this like i you know
you know pulling back from 50 yards and
and hit the target
um it worked and it worked and then the
next morning about 7 a.m i'm i'm up with
my kids you know drinking coffee and
i get a call on my cell phone from a 202
number
in tc right i say okay it worked
like something happened and then one's
calling me and then i get a call and uh
i
you know i've said this before so it's
it's not really private information and
he says
you know christopher this mark meadows
the chief of staff i'm calling on behalf
of the president
um you know he saw your segment on
tucker carlson he's tasked me to take
immediate action
wow and i said holy you know like this
is
this is this is the real deal so um
and then from there i thought i don't
know the bureaucratic process i think
it's going to go through
a process and a study committee and the
typical dc
process where they want to do something
and then maybe six months later it
happens
within 72 hours the omb director russ
vaught who i saw today
and is an amazing person um issued a
letter basically saying
none of this ever again and then three
weeks after that the full executive
order uh
signed by the president did this ban so
so what did it ban specifically what did
trump ban
so it's interesting it it's it's it's
thought of i think accurately as a ban
on critical race theory trainings in the
federal government um but
the executive order actually doesn't say
critical race theory anywhere in it
what they've done is is really smart
they instead of saying ban critical race
theory well what is critical race theory
the critical race theorists and the kind
of progressives who kind of espouse that
ideology
um change language at an amazingly rapid
rate
they throw up a turn actually you can't
debate it you can't talk about you can't
think about it it's so
fast and these languages they burn right
like they're going to toss up
you know some some new phrase why mixing
it's it's
it's persuasive for a quick minute and
then everyone hates it and then they
just
recycle it with something new so what
they said is we're gonna
categorize divisive concepts and the
divisive concepts are really simple
you can't stereotype scapegoat or demean
people on the basis
of their sex or their race um that's it
that's already illegal
that's already illegal um it's already
illegal but they they basically
codified it in in within the executive
agencies
they gave a directive saying anything
that falls under these divisive concepts
these categories of
stereotyping scapegoat and demeaning and
and then they did something really
brilliant they said
not only in the federal agencies and the
military but if you want to do business
with the federal government if you're a
large corporation most of them are large
corporations
um you can no longer do this anywhere in
your business
because we don't we don't want to work
with people who stereotype scapegoat and
demean
so this is so basically what they're
getting rid of
it's like sending white people on
retreats i guess was one of the things
on your website
they how the white men go and like
deconstruct their stuff or identity or
whatever
yeah so exactly so one of the most kind
of egregious examples was the sandia
national laboratories
this is the laboratory that designs our
nuclear arsenal
so this is a serious thing it's not like
the department of you know
dietary guidelines somewhere deep in the
health sector i mean
these people design our nukes that
protect the united states of america
this is a serious thing
and they had basically from the
directives from the very top they had
said
you know we need to address our white
privilege within
the the national laboratories and we've
hired a diversity training firm
literally called this is the firm that
contracted with the federal agency
white men as full diversity partners and
they specialize in and what they did for
the for the for the
trainers here they took white male
executives they put him on a three-day
retreat at a kind of luxury resort in
new mexico
and they set up this kind of grueling
process where they were saying you have
to deconstruct your white male identity
they put up on the board and had people
kind of they had they kind of fished for
people to make
associations said well white male
culture is associated with
mass killings the kkk
maga hats white supremacy these are all
of the kind of
evils that are lurking within your
identity
to the top nuclear weapons engineers in
the world
and then we're going to spend the next
day three days deconstructing that
identity
and forcing you to confront your white
privilege your male privilege your
heterosexual
sexual privilege and then at the end of
it they had them write letters to these
kind of
imaginary women and people of color
much along the lines of a kind of
chinese struggle session they're saying
you need to now people are writing apart
these grown men
you know being kind of bullied into
writing i am sorry for my privilege
it's embarrassing and it's completely
out i don't remember where i was reading
this maybe you guys might remember where
they were talking about the chinese
manipulation technique
for pows oh yeah what they would do is
they wouldn't ever have them come out
and be extremely overt they would say if
you want to eat you have to just simply
write
that the united states is not perfect
little things little tiny things and
they'd be and they'd be like oh well
that's fine of course
of course not perfect then the next time
they would say tell us one thing you
wish you could change about the united
states
and that was the way they opened the
door into getting them to saying
you know well i've already said that i
can certainly say this
and the amazing thing is that they do it
with social pressure
that's really the kind of most powerful
part of this
is that if you don't comply you are
somehow bad or you endorse some bad
thing so people's
fear uh people a lot of these folks in
the government agencies are
middle-aged people with families waiting
for a pension they don't want to rock
the boat
so they just do it and as soon as it's
like a sales techniques
um hey man you know um can i stop you
for a second
sure as soon as you get the first yes
i've hooked you in
you don't even need to yet that's like a
sales technique from you know i i i did
door-to-door sales when i was a teenager
like they always get the first yes right
you don't need it yes
you don't even need it yeah i used to do
street fundraising fundraising you know
i would do
so they do these trainings for people on
like how to stop people
hey do you have a minute to talk about
the environment no i don't do that you
know i would do
i walk up and go hey and stick my hand
out yeah and they would immediately grab
my hand and i'd shake it i'm here to
talk to you about why it's a physical
yes
yeah as soon as they reach that shaken
everyone does every person will shake
your hand
they can't leave while you're shaking
your hands and you've got about 10
seconds and you say
now let me show you this and you put the
clipboard in there the foundation of
your success
yeah that's the strong handshake yeah as
well it's not about strong it's it's
that
yeah the really good fundraisers would
say
shake their hand yeah and then before
you're done you're handing them the
clipboard
they grab it and now they're holding
your stuff and do not take it back
so you're like raising money for the
environment or for greenpeace
among many other companies yeah and so
this is it if they're holding your
clipboard
and they try giving it back to you you
just you cross your arms or you don't
want to cross your arms
it's it's defensive so you just like
hold your hands together and act like
you don't realize what they're trying to
do
but it's very hard to not shake the hand
right so if you're in a room with all of
your peers and
and high status people and you're in a
government agency and and everyone says
you have to
get up and identify yourself as a white
male and say that you know you're you're
here to deconstruct your identity
it's very hard to just say i'm going to
sit down and i'm not going to do it
right so and then the the critical race
theorists in to their credit they've
constructed the argument in a really
ingenious way
it's almost constructed like an
intellectual mouse trap
where if you dissent if you disagree
embedded in their argument if you
disagree that's an admission of guilt
so oh well you don't agree with this
well that's your white privilege
right that's your white fragility that's
your internalized
racial dominance or oppression um so
they've created a category that is
psychological in nature that is that is
new that is distinct from old forms of
manipulation and
even unconscious bias right i mean what
is unconscious biases
are they preferences experiences can you
measure it is it valid
a lot of real questions about that but
you know lost in that as we've moved
from a society to our credit
that has moved away from conscious bias
discrimination and racism that's a part
of the american history
to now we're worried about deep in the
recesses of your subconscious is there
some
hidden preference that we can measure
and try to change
we're not doing kind of mind con like
it's not even like
behavior control it's a form of kind of
uh kind of social control it's a form of
kind of um
deep kind of psychological conditioning
and that's no good thanks for checking
out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast we do the show live monday
through friday at 8pm so come back to
check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you